[Music]
on this wednesday night nova scotia
shuts down we need your help to slow the
spread
what's gone wrong in a province that was
once the envy of the country
new insight into how ontario failed
long-term care homes as that province
unveils a plan for paid sick leave
cutting surgeries alberta's sacrificed
to help hospitals full of coveted
patients
the misconduct allegations into general
jonathan vance the investigation
military police wanted to end
years ago and he kept solitary watch in
the capsule
as others walked on the moon we crew
felt the
weight of the world on our shoulders
tributes to astronaut
michael collins
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in alberta where there
is growing pressure on the premier
yesterday that province hit a record
11.4
positivity rate variants are spreading
fast hospitals are filling up and now
scheduled surgeries are being reduced
and heartbreaking stories are emerging
of younger people getting sick
heather yorick's west has our top story
about one family mourning
the sudden death of their teenage
daughter
seventeen-year-old sarah strait began
suffering from a sore throat
last week her sister had tested positive
for covid19
so she had been isolating at home her
first cova test came back negative
but when her condition worsened her
family called 9-1-1
the teen died in hospital on monday her
father believes covid19
was to blame well the number of covet
patients in hospital is still well below
alberta's second wave peak
a greater number of those patients are
requiring intensive care
and icus are nearly as full as they were
back in december
it does create some cause for concern
given that we know there's more to come
just based on simple mathematics with
the numbers that we're seeing
in calgary edmonton and across northern
alberta 30 percent of non-urgent
surgeries are now being postponed
even more procedures have had to be
canceled in hard hit fort mcmurray
northern alberta indigenous groups say
more restrictions are needed to protect
the health system from being overwhelmed
it's a fiasco it's a mess it's uh you
know it's astonishing that
the alberta government with everything
that they have before them
they dropped the ball on fort mcmurray
wood buffalo region the province says it
will send more vaccine to the area
for the next two weeks doses of the
johnson and johnson vaccine will head to
the hard-hit regions
of wood buffalo and banff adults as
young as 30 will become eligible for the
astrazeneca vaccine here too
all in an effort to protect more
essential workers
according to alberta health there are
active outbreaks at 12 oil sands work
sites accounting for more than
700 active cases with 40 percent of
infections reported at the horizon site
operated by canadian natural resources
angela johansen's dad works at horizon
and has been sick for the last nine days
since the 19th he's been in an isolation
room
at the camp at port mcmurray they told
him there's 200 people they got to take
care of so they can't
give him any special requests because he
asked for some suit
just one of more than 20 000 albertans
who are ill
as the province battles its third wave
heather urex west global news
calgary the first doses of the johnson
and johnson vaccine have now arrived in
canada roughly 300 000 doses landed this
afternoon at toronto's pearson airport
the doses arrived frozen and they must
be thawed before they're shipped to the
provinces
next week the alberta government plans
to send its share of those doses to
specific
areas premier jason kenney says
shipments expected in the next two weeks
will go
to two hard-hit communities banff and
the municipality of wood buffalo
and everyone aged 30 and up will be able
to get them
accelerating the vaccination program in
those communities which also happen to
be have younger populations
would be helpful in addressing
the outbreaks
in ontario after months of pressure from
the public and its own science
and medical experts the ontario
government has unveiled a plan for a
paid sick leave program
it's not in place yet it needs
legislation to be passed but if that
happens it will allow for three paid 60
days without the need for a sick note
global's queen's park bureau chief
travis dan raj is with me travis start
with what's in this plan
so this program is retroactive and goes
from april 19th to september 25th
it will cover three paid sick days for
part-time and full-time workers
the program will be administered by the
wsib that is the workplace safety
insurance board
payments will be up to two hundred
dollars a day and a worker will be
eligible if they're sick
they have symptoms they need to get
vaccinated or are waiting in isolation
for results here's what the minister of
labor said for ontario monty mcnaughton
and also andrea horvath the leader of
ontario's ndp
well look we're leading canada when it
comes to
protecting workers we're bringing in
protections for three paid sick days
the federal program runs for four weeks
we're there for workers through this
entire pandemic
i mean three days of of paid leave is
paid sick leave is
it's better than none but i don't know
where the premier thinks
that this is the best paid sick days
program
in north america it certainly is not
travis ontario wanted to piggyback on
the federal sick leave program and it's
now talking to the feds about that
correct that is correct they wanted to
top up the federal program by 500
additional dollars for a total of one
thousand dollars a week the fed said
that they wanted to see a provincial
program
first now that has happened so the ball
right now in ottawa's court donna
all right travis danraj in toronto
thanks in ontario a provincial emergency
order has been amended
allowing hospitals to transfer
chronically ill patients from hospitals
into
long-term care homes without their
consent to free up
hospital beds this temporary emergency
order will provide
hospitals with the flexibility to
transfer certain patients
those who've doctors have determined no
longer require hospital care
and could be better supported in a more
appropriate setting
to a long-term care or retirement home
this would be done in only the most
urgent of situations
ontario's health minister christine
elliott says hundreds of patients in
hospital are waiting to be discharged
to a long-term care home she says
patients or their families will be
consulted but there may be rare
situations where a patient is moved
without consent the order is being
criticized there are fears people will
be railroaded into homes they don't want
to be in
plus care homes have serious staff
shortages
one bioethicist though says this
i do think we have no choice and i do
think it's justified
i i just hope and believe that the
people will move heaven and earth to try
and get consent
uh from all the many people involved
with this and i believe they will
we know the terrible consequences of the
pandemic on residents in long-term care
in canada
today ontario's auditor general made the
failures clear by the time covet 19
started to ravage care homes last march
she says the system was not prepared or
equipped and it was obvious
aggressive infection prevention
detection and patient care actions were
needed and needed quickly
to prevent staggering death rates that
didn't happen
nearly 3 800 residents and 11 staff
members in ontario's long-term care
system
have died since the pandemic began and
the second wave hit ontario care homes
harder than the first eric sorenson
looks at the multiple failures in a
sector
that has long been neglected long-term
care residents rushed into ambulances
couldn't fully convey the horror
inside long-term care homes overcrowded
rooms
insufficient staffing and a virus
running rampant
the auditor general says neither the
government nor the long-term care sector
itself was sufficiently prepared for the
pandemic
or equipped to respond in fact some
patients with covet 19
at first were transferred into long-term
care homes i would say there could have
been more clarity and guidance the
safety of residents in long-term care
homes needs to be considered the
government acknowledges long-term care
should have played a bigger role in the
initial health care response
we have to have a much better integrated
system
where long-term care is seen to be
part of the healthcare sector
as a whole and there were unintended
consequences families were kept from
visiting to curb the spread of the virus
but says the report it had the effect of
further limiting care providers
maureen mcdermott could only wave to her
ailing mother inside
families and that connection that's
absolutely necessary and
the worst part for a child i think is to
have their parents suffer in any way
the report questioned a government
decision to discontinue comprehensive
inspections of long-term care homes to
deal with a years-long backlog of
complaints
on most findings however the minister
blamed the previous liberal government
i'm here to try and fix long-term care
but if the building's on fire and you're
running into it to to try and save
people
yeah i think that's pretty much what we
tried to do but we didn't start the fire
advocates say the current government
must accept its share of responsibility
we knew that long-term care was going to
be most susceptible
and this government stubbornly refused
to take care of our most vulnerable
the auditor general says there has to be
greater accountability and it can be
demonstrated
by ensuring seniors will be cared for
appropriately in the future
eric sorenson global news toronto
in nova scotia it is day one of a
two-week province-wide
lockdown daily new cases of covid 19
reached record levels there this week
there was a slight drop today though 75
new cases compared to 96 yesterday
i too am pleased to see that our case
numbers have gone down but it is only
one day
it's quite possible they may go back up
again tomorrow
what we want and what we're looking for
is a sustained
downward trend nova scotia is now
opening up appointments for the
astrazeneca oxford
vac scene to people aged 40 to 54.
that'll happen later this week
26 percent of nova scotians have had at
least one vaccine dose now the national
average is about
31 percent for months nova scotia had so
few cases it was the envy of much of the
country
but as jesse thomas explains what's
happening now as a reminder
how quickly things can change three
weeks ago the focus in nova scotia was
on the potential re-emergence of the
atlantic bubble
that would allow residents of new
brunswick pei nova scotia
and newfoundland and labrador to travel
freely between provinces again
without having to quarantine but on
tuesday nova scotia announced it was
going into a full
province-wide lockdown how did things
change so fast
variant virus got into the province
that's number one i think we found it
fairly quickly
because we were doing a fair amount of
testing nova scotia had been the envy of
the rest of canada with minimal cases
and few restrictions the province opened
its borders to the rest of atlantic
canada on april 7th
and at the same time allowed retail
establishments and restaurants to return
to 100
capacity because we were at an enviable
place
of having fewer restrictions it was able
to spread
and to go into community fairly quickly
on day one of the lockdown it was
noticeably quiet in downtown halifax
most retail businesses have been forced
to close only essential businesses like
grocery stores can remain open at 25
capacity the doors have closed at dear
friend a cocktail and wine bar that
opened
last summer owner matt boyle has had to
lay off his staff a third time
his new business doesn't qualify for
many of the government benefits
if you don't have comparables you can't
show reduction
so we don't qualify for the wage subsidy
we don't qualify for a lot of the
emergency benefits out there
nova scotia tested more than 10 thousand
residents on tuesday that's been one of
the province's best strategies in
containing the virus says barrett
we want to keep our testing higher than
anywhere else in canada
per capita at the beginning of the
outbreak before it gets out of control
74 members of the canadian armed forces
have been deployed across the province
to offer support at testing sites
this week alone 168 nova scotia health
employees have had to self-isolate as
per covet 19 protocols
jesse thomas global news halifax global
news has uncovered exclusive new details
about a decision
back in 2015 to name general jonathan
vance as canada's top
soldier he was appointed chief of the
defense staff by the conservative
government of stephen harper
and when vance was sworn in an
investigation was underway into his
conduct overseas now new documents
reveal that within hours of vance taking
command
military police recommended ending that
investigation
michael couture explains
at the same time as general jonathan
vance was being sworn in as the chief of
the defense staff in 2015
a military police investigation of him
was still
technically open that's according to
documents obtained by global news
through access to information laws the
investigation was looking into vance's
conduct while serving as deputy
commander
of nato allied joint force command in
naples italy
a position he held from 2013 until july
2014. the 455
heavily redacted document shows two
brief references
to concluding the investigation global
news has confirmed with the department
of national defense the recommendation
to end the investigation
came on july 17th the same day
vance was being sworn in as the
country's top soldier
four days later military police approved
the end of the investigation
there had been no reprimand of the
general a former chief of staff to then
prime minister stephen harper ray novak
testified before a comments committee
last month
about vance's appointment we were
briefed that the email
alleged an inappropriate relationship
during the general's time at nato
but contained no new information novak
testified that it still triggered a
review
by the military police however a week
later harper's national security adviser
told the prime minister no further
information regarding the allegation was
found
[Applause]
there remain questions about the chain
of command and the military police's
ability to investigate
sexual misconduct cases let alone one
involving canada's former top soldier
one of the women at the heart of the
allegations against vance says the
former cds told her
he was above investigation the cds told
me
he was untouchable he owned the cfnis
all of this comes as prime minister
justin trudeau claims no one in his
office knew allegations about vance were
a quote
metoo complaint opposition parties are
pushing to have his chief of staff katie
telford
testify before a commons committee
michael couter global news ottawa
india's deepening disaster coming up
sickness and death is everywhere as
countries
rush to help
in india covet 19 is still spreading
unchecked in just 24 hours another
record
more than 360 000 new infections
reported
and more than 3 000 reported deaths the
real number is believed to be
even higher india's official death toll
is now more than 200 thousand
crystal gomansi reports
his last visit to canada was a few years
ago
sudia khan patel's nephew thought he was
going to be
okay but babu as he called him didn't
make it
so he was you know somebody who always
used to watch zap us jokes and things
like that
so he was very active still you know
still a big part of our lives despite
being far away the struggles in
india are profound and heartbreaking
people are lining up for hours and
paying
random inflated prices for oxygen
desperate to save their loved ones and
death
doesn't end the nightmare crematoriums
around the country
can't keep up i have right now
14 relatives in india that are actively
infected with colvin
some of those are in health care and so
i'm getting first-hand accounts and
and everything you see on tv it's you
know it even that
doesn't relate how desperate the
situation is in the big cities
there are three known virus variants
circulating
but testing and sequencing are
inadequate
so the extent of the virus in india is
unknown
i feel like i'm running a clinic on
whatsapp honestly with all these
different chat groups and
what's your latest saturation they're
sending me their ct scan on whatsapp
two doctors who know the virus and feel
helpless one of the troubling things for
me is that he did die
alone without any family there which you
know has an icu doctor i've seen
unfortunately many times and it's
definitely been the hardest part of this
a gut-wrenching experience for far too
many
crystal gamson global news london
ahead what members of the canadian
military police wrote online about a
woman accusing a top soldier of
misconduct
there's a disturbing new development
tonight involving the sexual misconduct
allegations within the canadian military
a flight of memes and comments in a
private facebook group disparage one of
the women at the heart of the
accusations
the group includes both past and present
members of the canadian military
police the very team investigating two
defense chiefs including
general jonathan vance vance has denied
all allegations of inappropriate
behavior
including a claim from kelly brennan
that he fathered
two of her children abigail beeman has
the story and a warning there is
some bad language in it
disciplined by example canada's military
police motto
but facing two of its most sensitive
investigations yet
the question is what kind of example a
string of comments in a private facebook
group for current and former officers
mocks testimony by major kelly brennan
one of the women alleging sexual
misconduct by former defense chief
general jonathan vance if you sleep with
a senior rank you get good postings and
promotion to support the bastards but no
parenting and support from the senior
rank
reads one multiple memes and gifts two
giggity is a catchphrase from the tv
show family guy used to express
sexual excitement a military police
spokesperson tells global news they're
aware of the comments and the matter is
currently under review
survivors of sexual misconduct in the
canadian forces and
others question whether military police
should be trusted to handle sexual
misconduct cases
let alone one involving the country's
former top soldier
they don't have the independence of a
professional police force a civilian
police force
stu kellock served 40 years with the
canadian forces reserve
including 30 with the military police he
says every decision they make
is influenced by the chain of command
these are very dedicated
hard-working and committed individuals
who tried to do the right thing
but unfortunately their chain of command
often comes as an obstruction to that
it's heartbreaking policing expert
christian luprecht says the facebook
comments re-victimize those involved
it's exactly the sort of discourse that
civilian police forces have fought
really hard to root out from their
organizations
he says change has to come from the top
starting with defense minister harjud
sajin
we need the ministers to step in and
draw some clear red lines
a government source told global news
military police have not found any
currently serving military police
officers among those who posted the
comments
abigail beeman global news ottawa
he kept a watchful eye while his
colleagues made one giant leap for
mankind
next remembering the forgotten astronaut
a former astronaut who has been
described as the loneliest man in
history has died
michael collins stayed alone in the
command module during the historic 1969
mission to the moon while
neil armstrong and buzz aldrin went on
the first moonwalk
he said later the earth looked like a
fragile little thing you could obscure
with your fingernail the others got all
the glory but collins was critical to
that mission and the tributes to him
today make that clear
david aiken reports it's one small step
for man while neil armstrong was taking
that giant leap for mankind
michael collins then 38 years old was by
himself
in the command module flying circles
around the dark side of the moon
collins armstrong and buzz aldrin were
the three-man crew in the most famous
flight in history
the one that carried human beings to the
surface of the moon
for the first time and for most of that
mission collins was the pilot
basically he was in the mother ship
making sure everything worked
an absolutely vital role he was the
keystone of that mission
yes indeed they got the flag up now
collins never griped about missing his
chance to walk on the moon
or the fame and glory that came to
armstrong and aldrin
the thing i remember most is the view of
planet earth from a great distance
tiny very shiny blue and white
bright beautiful serene
and fragile mike was wise enough to
see that his place in history was very
important but he wasn't going to go
along with some of the ridiculous
celebrity that can come with that
he was the perfect person to be on that
first mission collins will also be
remembered for his 1974 autobiography
carrying the fire widely considered the
best account of space flight
ever penned by one who flew people have
this curiosity they want to know about
the universe they want to know more
about how
it works how it affects their lives
collins may not have walked on the moon
but he was the one who flew humanity
there first and brought its first
explorers
home safely
and that is global national for this
wednesday buzz aldrin is now the only
surviving crew member of that apollo 11
mission and today
he tweeted this dear mike wherever you
have been or will be you will always
have the fire to carry us deftly
to new heights and to the future we will
miss you
may you rest in peace i'm donna friesen
thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye